music food and black owned small  businesses filled the streets of  downtown today the arts district playing  host to a juneteenth celebration the now  federal holiday marks the end of slavery  here in the u.s it's officially on  sunday then observed monday but the  community was happy to come together for  today  this is very something special for the  community you know us  rising up and celebrating together as  one as a whole  around the world we thought the wind was  going to hold us back but we're not  allowing that to hold us back and that  is significant for what today means it  means do not hold us back we are alive  and we are here we are thankful we're  happy for that  also downtown another celebration this  one at the discovery children's museum  governor siselek joined other local  leaders to mark the important date in  our country's history dancers were on  hand for a special performance and the  museum hosted other workshops throughout  the day